is an atheist closer to truth than a
person who believes in God
so I'm a non-theist which I which means
I think the shared set of
presuppositions between the theist and
the atheist are actually what needs to
be rejected
can you uh explain that further yes I
can and uh and I want to point out by
the way that they're
uh there are lots of non-theistic uh
religious Traditions
um so I'm not I'm not I'm not coming up
with a sort of Airy fairy category yeah
and what's the difference in non-theism
agnosticism and Atheism so non-theists
think that the theist and the atheists
share a bunch of presuppositions for
example it's that sacredness is to be
understood in terms of a personal being
that is in some sense the Supreme Being
and that the right relationship to that
being is to have a correct set of
beliefs
I reject all of those claims so both the
theist and the atheists in their modern
version yes yes in which do you reject
it in the sense that you don't know or
do you reject it in a sense that
you believe that
each one of those presuppositions is
likely to be not true the latter I both
on reflection argument and personal
experimentation and ex and experience
I've come to the conclusion that those
shared propositions are probably not
true which one is the most Troublesome
to you the personal being the the kind
of accumulation of everything into one
being that ultimately created stuff
so for me there's two and they're
interlocked together I'm not trying to
dodge a question yeah it's that the idea
that
the ground of being is some kind of
being I think is a fundamental mistake
it's void of being no no no like
the ground of being is some kind of
being no no turtles all the way down the
ground of being is not itself any kind
of being being is not a being it is the
ability for things to be which is not
the same thing as a being
our Humans Beings we are beings this
glass is a being this table is a being
but when I ask you
how are they all in being you don't say
by being a glass or by being a table or
by being a human you want to say no no
there's something ah Underneath It All
and then you realize it can't be any
thing this is why many mystical
Traditions Converge on the idea that the
ground of being is no thingness
which is you know which you use normally
pronounced as nothingness but if you if
you put the hyphen back in you get the
original intent no thingness
and
that is bound up with okay what I need
to do in order to be in relationship
with so it's a misconstruing of Ultimate
Reality as a Supreme Being
which is a category mistake to my mind
and then that my relationship to it that
sacredness is a function of belief and I
have been presenting you an argument
through most of our discussion that
meaning is at a deeper level than
beliefs and propositions and so that is
a misunderstanding of sacredness because
I take sacredness to be that which is
most meaningful and it connected to what
is most real
and theists think of what uh of
sacredness is what they think of
sacredness as a property of a particular
being
God
and that the way that is Meaningful to
them is by asserting a set of
propositions or beliefs now I want to
point out that this is what I would Now
call Modern or common theism you go back
into
the classical periods of Christianity
you get a view that's really radically
different from how most people
understand theism today
okay so let me uh this is an interesting
question that I usually think about in
the form of mathematics but
so in that case if meaning is sacred in
your non-theist view
is meaning created or is it discovered
so there's a Latin word that doesn't
separate them called inventio
and I would say that and before you say
oh well give me a chance because you
participate in it
you've experienced an Insight yes did
you make it happen
the the Insight did you make it happen
or did what did you do like can you do
that I'm gonna I need an Insight no this
is what I do to make an Insight oh I see
yeah in some sense it came from
elsewhere right but you didn't just
passively receive it either you're
engaged and involved in it that's why
you get right so that's what I mean by
you participate in it you participate in
meaning so you do think that is both
yes you do think it's both I mean that's
not a trivial thing
to understand
because a lot of time we think when you
think about a search for meaning
you think it's like you're going through
a big house and you open each door and
look if it's there and so on as if there
is going to be a glowing orb that you
discover yeah
um and but at the same time
I'm somebody that
uh based on the chemistry of my brain
have been extremely fortunate to be able
to discover Beauty in everything uh in
the most mundane and boring of things I
am as David Foster Wallace said
unborable
I could just sit in a room uh just like
playing with the tennis ball or
something and be excited um basically
like a dog I think endlessly
um so to me meaning is the
um
created like because I could create
meaning out of everything but of course
it doesn't require a partner
it does require dance Partners whatever
it does require the tennis ball but
honestly that's what you know a lot of
people that I don't necessarily and
we'll talk about about I don't practice
meditation but people who meditate very
seriously like you know the entire days
for months kind of thing they talk about
being able to discover meaning and just
uh the the wind or something like they
they just the the breath and everything
just subtle sensory experiences yes give
you deep fulfillment